we begin this morning with a major
economic war averted Mexico has agreed
to us demands that it tighten its
borders to stop the flow of illegal
Central American immigrants from
crumbing into the u.s. through Mexico
the deal spares Mexico from having to
pay steep tariffs that were to go into
effect next week Mexico is the United
States third largest trading partner
those tariffs raised fears that they
could [ __ ] some US businesses and
raise prices for American consumers on
everything from cars to product produce
Ouisa Jang is at the White House with
more weeds a good morning good morning
Anthony the White House was fully
prepared to set these tariffs in motion
but after nearly 12 hours of negotiating
yesterday the US and Mexico reached a
last-minute deal the agreement however
does not include the most dramatic
measure President Trump had been pushing
for which would have made it much harder
for migrants to seek asylum in the u.s.
just three hours after returning to the
White House following his European trip
President Trump made the announcement on
Twitter the tariffs scheduled to be
implemented by the US on Monday against
Mexico are hereby indefinitely suspended
the president wrote Mexico in turn has
agreed to take strong measures to stem
the tide of migration through Mexico and
to our southern border the deal came
after three days of lengthy negotiations
to stop the flow of mostly Central
American migrants into the US by
traveling through Mexico in a joint
declaration Mexico agreed to increase
its enforcement efforts along their
southern border with Guatemala including
deploying their National Guard troops
Mexico also agreed to take action
against human smuggling and trafficking
organizations and the US will continue
to return migrants seeking asylum back
to Mexico as they wait for their cases
to play out on an expedited basis
mexico's secretary of foreign affairs
said both countries fared well I think
fair balance because they have more
drastic measures and proposals at the
start and we have reached some
President Trump had threatened to impose
a 5% tariff on all Mexican goods coming
into the u.s. starting Monday it would
have increased by 5% every month capping
at 25% if a deal was not reached when
you were the piggy bank that everybody
steals and robs from and they deceive
you and they've like they've been doing
for 25 years tariffs are a beautiful
thing it's a beautiful word if you know
how to use them properly businesses
across the country were rattled by the
president's threat including peter testa
who owns a produce supply company in
chicago it sauce to pay yes we have to
pay the max if you tell Mexico we're
gonna charge you five percent more for
everything you bring in so they charge
us five percent more we pay the five
percent I don't know what anybody else
paying we pay and then we have to pass
that on the consumer a president Trump
had always rejected those concerns and
this morning he is tweeting confidence
in this deal with Mexico but if the
measures do not do enough to control
illegal immigration both sides have
agreed to continue talking and go back
to the drawing board to take even
further action Dana a very big if we
sure thank you very much